November 6 1983 the young boy goes  missing in Hawkins Indiana he's  pronounced dead but turns up alive days  later local authorities provide no  explanation and so began a series of  strange happenings across the globe  beginning in 1984 with the Olympic Games  Russian boycott or interference from  beyond somewhere in a secret lab coke is  becoming new coke plans announced four  armed satellites in space sunspots the  size of Jupiter obscure our only source  of light radio stations begging us to  relax gremlins ghosts mermaids cyborgs  not even a year after the boy's  disappearance in the world starts to  turn upside down  you  [Music]  you